one of the linchpins of on-prem systems
is the aggressive use of IP addresses to
balance scatter and manage traffic
coming into your environment this is
built into the configuration of your
routers firewalls and most of the
hardware and software you've got lying
around as you migrate portions of your
environment to the cloud however you
have to be aware that this IP address
logic will change in various ways as
such it's crucial to plan ahead for your
IP address changes that could affect
your workloads and how they interact
with internal and public network traffic
in this episode I'll be covering private
and public IPS on Google cloud and how
you can achieve remappable IP addresses
for your cloud resources stay tuned the
main challenge is that you can't simply
move your existing IP addresses to the
cloud along with your services cloud
providers and data centers have a
limited pool of IP addresses that they
own and they often reuse previously
assigned IPs in order to maximize them
the result is that your services will
receive a dynamically assigned internal
and public IP address which by default
are ephemeral
meaning if you restart those instances
you'll lose those IPS for companies in
this situation there are basically two
solutions which you could run through
defined firewall rules by using tags
instead of IP addresses forward traffic
through a managed load balancer with a
static IP of course both will work but
they both come with a large downside as
your cloud IP is continued to change
they'll break any dependencies your
services might have on those IPS which
are hard coded or require a network
admin to manually change which can
quickly turn into a nightmare of
maintenance for example let's say you
spin up your first back-end machines in
the cloud and decide to tear them down
for a period of time to save on costs
suddenly when you're ready to get them
up and running again you notice that you
lost those dynamically assign IPS only
to find new ones now you have to
reconfigure your on-prem app and any
firewall rules to point to the new
public IP of your cloud back-end this
can grow pretty tiresome and unwieldy
over large environments thankfully
Google cloud allows you to get around
the situation by reserving static IPS
for your services so if your VM is shut
down
you can retain the same internal and
public IPS when you spin it back up what
this means is that you can feel relaxed
knowing that if you point a forwarding
rule firewall role or application to
your cloud instance IP from within or
out of the V PC network you won't need
to reconfigure the IPS each time you
shut down your instances this really
comes in handy if you are dependent on a
specific IP address for your service and
need to prevent your teammates from
being able to use that address and the
best part you can even promote a
previously ephemeral IP to be a static
one helping you cut corners in a few
places let's dive into IP is a bit more
for compute engine you can assign one
internal and one public IP address for
each VM it's important to note that you
don't need public IPS for your VMs
within the same V PC to communicate and
this can really help network performance
on the other hand if you need the VM to
communicate with the internet or any VM
in a different VP C Network your VM has
to have a public IP address unless
you've set up some sort of proxy or VPN
and the other network for both cases of
internal and public IP addresses you can
choose ephemeral and static IPs let's
start with internal IPs when you create
a VM unless you specify an internal IP
within your subnet range Google will
just assign your VM and ephemeral
internal IP from your subnet range you
can reserve one later on and assign it
to your VM if you decide you need a
static internal IP later for public IP
is the same applies unless you assign
your VM a reserved static public IP
Google will assign an ephemeral public
IP randomly from a pool or you can
choose not to assign a public IP
whatsoever which can be good for keeping
instances from being exposed to the
public Internet and reduce security risk
later on you can always assign one
there's also a way to create a custom
public IP on GCP as well but I'll point
you to the documentation linked below
let's walk through IP setup let's take a
look at a VM I just created with apache2
installed deployed in u.s. East one
first head to the networking tab
by default you're given an ephemeral
internal and public address I'm going to
remove the ephemeral public IP and you
can now see it has no public IP address
it's important to note that if you're an
internal VM talking to other internal
VMs then you need to be using the
internal address for the best
performance otherwise your internal VM
has to travel back to the public
internet which can slow it down now as I
mentioned by default your VMs will use
ephemeral public IPs
but sometimes you need static ones and
that won't change over time thankfully
you can create this right in Google
cloud go to the network tab and then in
external IP addresses create a static
one and note that we can also just
promote an ephemeral one you want to
create the IP in the same region as the
instance unless you're doing global
forwarding because static IP is our
regional resources you can assign the IP
to the instance right from here and now
you see we have a new static public IP
address assigned to the instance and as
long as you have the right firewall set
up to allow HTTP traffic on port 80 now
you can see that we have access to the
web page through the new static IP
address once you understand how IP
addresses are affected when different
actions are performed in your overall
architecture you start to realize the
importance of using remappable IP
addresses especially for a front end
servers in the cloud but what if you
don't want a public IP address in order
to maintain higher security yet you
still want to be able to do things like
fetch updates from the public Internet
stay tuned for the next episode to find
out how and remember optimizing your
network means freeing up your bandwidth
[Music]